i've heard that you have this practice
where you retreat separately and find
the source of the problem being yourself
when you have a fight a conflict with
your oh sure i can imagine that it can
be one-sided at times
at least in the beginning where you
aren't able to come up with an
idea as to how the problem was you and
then you get together the person says
yeah the problem is miso something
you're like yeah
the problem actually at this time was
you so uh no no
not usually like usually
well if there's a fight if so there's an
argument and you go off to your own
place then you think if there's anything
in your life that you've done that may
have brought this
argument up not neces so it's not
necessarily about actually the argument
because sometimes the argument has
nothing to do with why
like often the argument has nothing to
do with actually what's wrong
maybe you're uh late on on something and
you bark
at your wife when she comes in it has
nothing to do with you being
angry at your wife or that she intruded
it was that you
you have a project that you're late on
and so you have to look you have to
separate and find out if there's a cause
to this
argument that you hadn't seen before
that may have
come up right then and
shown you that there was something to
pay attention to
it's something you know an argument is
something to pay attention to
because you might learn something and
those are gifts
because the next time you won't have
that same argument it won't come up
anymore
if you can figure it out